- So then I said to him,
"James, that's not my cat.
"That's my dad."
(both laugh)
- That is so funny.
That reminds me of the time
that my cat got out of the house
and climbed that
palm tree, and--
- Oh, you already
told me that one.
- Oh.
- Have I ever told you about
the time that my ex-girlfriend
thought a tree was a mammal?
- Yeah, you told me that.
I ever tell you about
the time that my ex tree
thought my girlfriend
was a mammal?
- Yeah, you did
tell me that one.
Did I ever tell
you about that time
that I almost hung myself
with my tie on purpose?
- Yes.
Did I ever tell you about the
time that I shot a squirrel
and I loved watching it bleed?
- Yeah, have I ever
told you about the--
- Yeah, have I ever told
you about the time that I--
- Yeah, have I ever told--
- Yeah, have I--
- Yeah.
- I guess we've run out of
things to say to each other.
- Really, we haven't even
known each other that long.
- Just happens
that way sometimes.
- I guess we'll
just be quiet now.
Oh!
- Don't.
It's over.